So they've identified
a flaw in your game.
But you aren't sure about how to fix it.
What do you do?
Well you can make an educated guess.
But the best developers don't guess.
They know, they use A/B testing,
which is testing different versions
of a game at the same time.
And seeing which version gets
the best response from players.
It's called AB, because the simplest
test compared two versions.
An A and B version.
The A version is given to
one half of the games users.
And the B is given to the other half,
and
we see how each group of users respond.
These tests can help you repair any
game content that you're unsure about.
From the color scheme to game content.
And you can test out two versions or
as many as you want.
Let's walk through an example of
creating effective AB testing scenarios.
Let's say we've made a platform a game,
where we jump around and
shoot enemies to advance levels.
Our analytics have shown us that only
20% of players make it past Level 3.
We think that the level might
be too hard, so let's change it.
Let's test out different levels of
difficulty and see how users respond.
To see how players respond to different
scenarios, we can use A/B testing,
which is a method of testing that
compares the performance of two or
more game versions A and B and so on.
The most effective A/B testing
scenarios are designed to test out
one main variable, X,
Y, count, color, etc.
And they monitor one or two results
like level completion or profitability,
things like that.
Our game versions are distributed
amongst our players.
And so there are usually only
2-4 versions tested at one time.
So for
our game we want to change level 3.
Let's create three different test cases
where we change the number of enemies
and see how many more players
will complete the level.
You also want to test your original
version and comparison to the new ones.
So we have an A, original version.
A version B with 10% fewer enemies.
And a version C with 20% fewer enemies.
The next step is to distribute
these versions to our players, so
that about a third of our
players play each version.
This is usually done by percentage.
So, we have 33%, 33% and 34%,
which adds up to a total of 100%,
distributed to versions A, B, and C.
Then we get our results and
see how many players complete the level.
We see that only 20% of our group
A players completed the level.
80% of group B completed level 3, and
70% completed level 3 for group C.
So both B and
C seem like a lot better options than A.
And maybe the reason that C isn't as
high as B is because it's too easy, so
people get bored playing.
Either way, A/B testing let's us know for
sure that version B is our best option.